pues raúl la posibilidad es muy limitada
teniendo en cuenta precisamente que el
senado es controlado por esa mayoría
republicana en eeuu para que una ley sea
probada tiene que pasar precisamente por
la aprobación de la cámara de
representantes- en este caso en el
proyecto de descriminalización paso ya
la cámara de representantes- con 226
votos a favor 164 en contra pero falta
entonces la aprobación del senado y
después la firma del presidente trump el
líder de el senado el líder republicano
del senado mitch mcconnell dijo hoy que
hay que enfocarse más bien en otros
proyectos proyectos como en la
aprobación del presupuesto y también la
aprobación del paquete de ayuda de cara
a la crisis económica derivada del
comité sin embargo lo que dicen varios
analistas acá en washington es que
mientras más empresarios se metan en el
negocio del cannabis pues más presión
para tener los republicanos para aprobar
esta descriminalización de la marihuana
los demócratas esperan hasta el 5 de
enero para lograr definir la mayoría en
el senado y así ver qué tanto empujan
esta iniciativa a raúl
ahora cristóbal que apoyo popular tiene
la legalización de la marihuana a nivel
estatal y qué efectos podría tener la
aprobación de esta ley
pues según la última encuesta hecha por
gallup en octubre el 68% de los
estadounidenses apoya la legalización de
algún tipo de la marihuana en las
últimas elecciones del pasado 3 de
noviembre cinco estados legalizaron real
de alguna forma el uso de la marihuana
de hecho de esos 53 mississippi dakota
del sur y montana votaron por donald
trump quiere decir que en estados
republicanos también hay apoyo para la
legalización de la marihuana en cuanto
al tema de los efectos legales pues esto
facilitará los conflictos que hay entre
estados que tienen una política más
liberal liberalizada en cuanto al uso de
la marihuana y el gobierno federal pero
también permitirá pues la
comercialización mucho más fácil de el
cannabis medicinal o recreativo